so when he's here
uh if you guys watch The Green Room
episode we did you'll understand my
point and I'll say a few things
I don't know for sure if it was staged
but what I know is they didn't confirm
the hotel that we got for them
they had initially asked that we get him
a flight for the morning of and leaving
immediately after the show it's not
possible to do that so they said okay
you know then the next morning is fine
when they arrived and the person
coordinating says I have your address
they said don't worry about it so after
everything goes down I'm told we never
actually gave him the address to where
they were staying the night they didn't
want it and they had a jet already
waiting for them at Frederick with a
crew available ready to go and there was
Paparazzi outside so I'm like I don't
know man but if you watch the Green Room
episode you'll see that yay was very
calm asking us questions smile on his
face talking about everything and there
was like no issue but as soon as the
camera turns on and we go live on the
show his demeanor flips I gotta talk
about Nazism man because this is like
we're just talking about what reps into
wakanya and everything this it's all in
the vein Tim don't worry I got you baby
um I got you baby I like that not
Sublime being racist is is legal in the
American Republic breaking down
buildings smashing buildings burning
buildings is something that Nazis did
and that's also something that happened
two years ago Kanye was not burning down
buildings Kanye was being racist if you
want to call the Jewish people a race
which I I also have issues with because
I if you don't believe in God you're not
Jewish the tenet of being Jewish is that
you believe in a God and you understand
what it is and if you just because of
who your parents are in your social club
it's not a social club
you don't don't be don't be violent do
not those are the things I mean these
you're allowed to talk and say that's
the Great
so well that's why hate speech should be
allowed because there's bad stuff you
can hate you know in the world so you
should be able to hate bad stuff so
that's why you should be able to have
hate speech but you shouldn't be able to
incite any sort of violence yeah Laura
Loomer came on the show and she was like
hey guys I'm Jewish I was debating
listen to this I gotta bring up Laura
Loomer I want to shout her out so she's
spreading this thing in telegram today
that Marjorie Taylor green and I had a
sexual Affair so I just want to debunk
that did you know no even though
Marjorie is a beautiful lady and and
I'll be honest I would if I could but I
haven't so I I so I can't so you know
that's the that's the real facts but to
be honest uh this is the sad reality for
congresswoman green for me even if we
did have sex I'm saying for me to leak
it that would be huge that'd be great
right for her it only you know hurts her
I just want to say the God's honest
truth it didn't happen I'd probably leak
it if it did it's my point AOC would be
mad at you exactly so that's why you
know it's not true but I just hate it
for her because I just hate it for her
because it's just so provably false and
she's the one looks bad for you know
even sleeping with this pile of junk
Prime Time 99 even though I'm a pimp on
a blimp a lot of ladies want to take a
ride still it just makes her look bad
because I'm just a you know Joe Blow
comedian from Dallas Texas how is any of
this real life this week has been just
really crazy
okay this is a vague question do you
think it's a simulation for real like
this I don't know I don't know I almost
believe in reincarnation I do believe in
the Creator they're like I just I don't
I really hate I talk about this all the
time the idea of the big bang and that
we evolved from Pawn scum and that just
nothing you know literally like
everything came from nothing over time
just for me doesn't even live but you
got to get way more nuanced than that
because I think the idea of like
evolution in pondscom can be the how not
the why like there's people there's even
a biogenesis we can't recreate that I
mean it's just the fact that like you
think every single person here you and
me the cat like you see that cat it's so
beautiful it's just such a beautiful
creature like we are not the same it's
just I just do believe there is a
Creator and and does that mean that
there's you know more levels to this I
do believe I just do believe there is
that's I feel like this is a God thing
like this really is we're part of
something which is God's the
consciousness of real God like it is
there it's this is the which turns out
abrahamic religions Judea Judaism
Christianity Islam they were all right
Ian started now so like Kanye's going
through some like channeling you know
he's and it's coming out all wrong in a
lot of ways in a lot of ways not but in
a lot of ways it's coming out wrong
let's we'll uh I want to
let me tell you
I was watching this uh interview with
yay and Jones and Fuentes and I said
these are three guys who are having
everything taken away from them yay is
gonna he's gonna lose his kids he uh I
mean maybe what happened so I was just
talking about how his demeanor was so
different
he was on his phone the whole time the
show starts he's totally different
maybe that's when he found out about his
kids he mentioned something to us before
the show about his wife's lawyer being
really good like he looked at me he was
like damn I watched it looks like you've
got a good idea though he got 50 50 with
200k a month uh well so but my point is
he's sitting here right before the show
starts and everything was fine he gets
mad and leaves may have nothing to do
with us at all yeah maybe maybe it was
planned maybe because he's on his phone
he gets that message I I get it so he's
a guy who then says on the show they're
trying to put me in jail they're
freezing my accounts he's going through
a divorce they're taking everything away
from him they're saying you know Adidas
try stealing the name of his shoes Alex
Jones they're coming after for 2.75
trillion and Fuentes at one point was
banned from flying you take three guys
who have nothing left to lose and you're
good you'll get this or or or more and
this is why I'm I oppose cancel culture
and I say we should be having
conversations with these people let them
come in to the circle and work out the
issues because if you just say never not
a chance then they'll go wherever they
can go and they'll say we have nothing
to lose and they'll just do whatever
they want well that's what's kind of
stuck too about that interview as soon
as Nick was going to talk which
everybody wants to hear from Nick I mean
you know he's one of the most polarizing
people within any political ideology
whether you're on the left lining or
right lane and as soon as he's about to
say something then Kanye leaves it just
sucks Nick is so interesting he's one of
the most interesting people whether you
like him or not and it just kind of
sucks so that we miss out on that
opportunity even as much as almost as
Kanye because when you listen to Kanye
talk he doesn't he can't articulate his
opinions and that's my opinion even
though Kanye's a brilliant artist I just
don't think publicly speaking on these
subjects in a long-form podcast is his
specialty it seems like he almost wants
to get canceled he was wearing a
Balenciaga mask today on the Alex Jones
uh pop you know interview when he was
here he was wearing a Balenciaga jacket
people are getting canceled because they
don't disavow Valencia Balenciaga he's
still wearing it as he's talking about
the most craziest outlandish things that
he knows will get people talking about
it we'll get people riled up some people
are saying that this is a deliberate
suicide of his career
um I think that's also another
possibility here some people are saying
that there's clear you know problems
mentally here who knows I I don't know I
I can't really quantify it I'm just kind
of you know why she's just shocked at
all this to be honest with you why is he
wearing a Balenciaga mask it's a [ __ ]
masks it's 160 Balenciaga I think it's
he's indicating that he's been gimped by
the that establishment I think that's
what that is supposed to I mean he's
worn it for concerts before as well mind
you and then Jones even made the point
is it really even him he said maybe I'll
take the mask off is it really even yeah
he's not Andy Kaufman
that'd be brilliant if he did I mean
then they say there's like oh the real
conspirito is he a clone I mean I don't
believe that either but I mean he's you
know Kanye he's not he's not his right
state of mind and his mom did die you
know that that messes you up I know
that's not an excuse for him to act
insane and become a you know a radical
Nazi but I don't think he really is I
just I think he's a little misunderstood
as well as as crazy as he's being right
now regarding this is good I want a
question for you particularly about um
becoming like the Andy Kaufman character
becoming the villain for Society for
them to focus on I kind of did that in
2010 it didn't work out like I just
angered upset the environment instead of
like creating a bunch of good around me
but do you think one do you think that
he's he or Nick or Milo are doing that
and do you think that there's any value
to it no because it's like I'm not an
expert but it's Saul alinsky's Rules for
Radicals and that's kind of like using
the less you know guidebook against him
and like you know they would use
creativity to protest and stuff him
speaking about it he needs to be using
his best methodology which would be
music to get his point across so he's
not doing that so he's just being it's a
waste of talent but in Saul's you know
in Saul linsky's rules for radical it's
like you accuse the people of what
you're actually doing so he's not being
nuanced he's not being smart he's just
being like Hitler quote unquote in the
video game I don't get in trouble but
he's saying Kanye West I don't want them
to edit this is saying Hitler is you
know not a bad person so that is what
Kanye West is saying and that is just
two nobody is ever going to drive with
that under any circumstance I I so I
think I think it was really good that
Alex Jones had them on because look at
what we got to see everybody can make up
their mind about exactly what happened
and I said I believe this is a strong
argument for free speech if Alex was
censored and they were behind if they
and they were just hanging out in his
living room saying all this stuff nobody
would have any idea what yay believed
and what yay was was was working on or
working towards or who he was
associating with uh you might you might
likewise whatever he's entitled to his
opinion he's entitled to being a human
and believing what he wants to believe
because Alex Jones had them on a talk
about it they just said everything
now I'm curious your thoughts about uh
Alex Jones is uh demeanor I suppose and
I'll just come out and say when Kanye
outright says
you know he denies certain elements of
the Holocaust I'll put it that way
Alex Jones just says oh yeah Reagan said
that you know and and then and then what
is what does Jones say that I think
Hitler did Target and kill some people
and it's just like
can't can't Jones just come out more
definitively and be like look man you
know like there are there's people on
record there's historical record
what do you guys think about you know
how he handled the interview well
there's also that thing when you have
guests on your show you're trying to be
nice to them so I don't know maybe he's
just trying to you know appease his
guess that's no excuse but I and I've
talked to Alex I've been on a show he
always does that and I know Luke has a
relationship with him but and and this
is once again I'm I'm
I am defending everybody tonight but I'm
almost doing it to be you know a
contrarian but I think Alex Jones is
very nice to his guests he wants to
please Kanye he realizes this is huge
for him this is a huge bump so he
realizes you know business-wise this
would be very a very key relationship
for him to build so I think that's why
he's trying to appease to him but also
you can have that caveat oh well you
know he's not he didn't go full what did
they say in that movie Tropical Thunder
yes yes yes
um yes it takes a lot to leave Alex
Jones speechless and uncomfortable
because of speech and Kanye West did it
um and Alex had an easy way out here I
think you know you should always be
genuine when you're doing these type of
type of broadcasts if if anyone here
says something that I disagree with I'm
going to bring it up and say hey I see
things differently we have discussions
we have debates we have arguments all
the time here on this broadcast because
we're we're honest with each other we're
genuine and I felt like Alex was kind of
going along with it and feeling
extremely uncomfortable not knowing what
to do not disagreeing not pushing back a
lot he did say that that uh that yay has
a Hitler fetish
um he did push back a little bit but
when when we're talking about these
short clips making the rounds of the
internet there's something there that
you always gotta kind of point out being
like hey are you on the side of Prescott
Bush hey are you on the side of of of of
Margaret Sanger George Soros Arnold
Schwarzenegger because these figures
also so endorsed this larger ideology
that now you're promoting you're really
you're really with with uh Arnold
Schwarzenegger who says he he really
loves he he really adored and liked you
know Hitler and he had a father that was
also tied to the SS I confronted Arnold
Schwarzenegger about this face to face
by the way in one of my YouTube videos
on we are changed but
um again that could have been a very
easy out for Jones but he didn't he
didn't do it which is weird I think if
he I think if Joe Alex probably thought
if he told Kanye no Hitler did Kill six
million Jews that Kanye would have got
up and walked out like he's probably
like oh how do I not make Kanye walking
I mean you guys and then once again I
carry the water but Alex Jones is
arguably one of the greatest
broadcasters of all time and when it
comes to internet and comes to Legendary
and comes to Alex Jones's right and some
of the stuff that he foresaw but right
now he is slipping he's under you know
so much stress with the with all these
constant lawsuits so that's what I'm
saying he's not his normal self so yeah
too yeah yeah either both of them that's
why they're both kind of a little
desperate right now just just you know
to defend them a little bit with their
behavior when yay came in to do the show
on Tuesday Monday Tuesday Monday he was
like they're trying to put me in jail
we're like what are you talking about
he's like they're trying to hit me with
that Harley well and that Harley
passionate guy which Luke brought up
that worked for the Canadian military
psyop you know organization whatever it
was did say like oh we're gonna put you
on drugs and your visits with your
children are going to be terrible that's
weird that's psychological manipulation
when you throw in the kids that's what
like an ex-wife does you know especially
with like the trans stuff that's what
happens in a lot of the instances where
there's a young kid that's you know
transitioning it's oftentimes like a
parent that has beef with the other
parent yeah and there's an apparent
encouraging it yeah that's oftentimes
the case
he got drugged by 2018 or whenever that
was they drugged him up he's in a place
that not I don't think many humans can
identify with personally because he's
such a focal point and that kind of
stress you know and then to think that
handlers might actually not have your
best interests in mind that's just going
to mess people up you know but hearing
him hearing they were going to hit him
with a 50 million or however much this
tax bill was is like that's probably
what was going through his mind 50
million I think that's that's nuts
that's like what kind of stress that
would put somebody under yep yeah and
they can just say it and what do you do
like oh you owe us this money and that's
what I was we talked about the 87 000
IRS agents and this is this is the thing
they do you'll be like you're working
class one day you get a letter in the
mail saying you know we don't have to
audit you just owe us 600 bucks and then
what do you do you you're not gonna you
have to pay it they can just do that and
that's I think everybody understands the
stresses of dealing with the IRS and
they do it already and they're going to
be doing it a lot more especially if you
don't report anything or you know over
six hundred dollars you're you're going
to be in trouble they're going to punish
you thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time